good morning and thank you maria for
that nice introduction and to frank in
absentia for helping us host and thank
you to all that we're coming to our
centenary event so I think I should
start by actually examining the the name
of the event which is problematic in
several ways first of all to make the
declaration why books still matter is to
beg the question do books still matter
art books to matter still and to beg the
question is to risk sounding
self-justifying and anachronistic books
have a lot of explaining to do these
days bibliophiles and even publishers
are treated with a fair amount of
suspicion and who can blame them most of
us carry on like fetishists you can
often hear us gushing about the
beautiful object of the book that seven
hundred year old feet of perfect
engineering you might see us in raptures
over the grain of paper or the pacing of
illustrations the compliment of typeface
and design we will bore you with the
sensual pleasure of the book its smell
and feel the way in which a fine book
ages this relatively benign defense of
the book can be dismissed as a
sentimental mumblings of luddites who
won their off-hours argue for the
reinstitution of the Lyceum the debating
society and the lecture platform acting
like that certain horse who in 1911
turns his head slowly as he feels the
rumbling heat of the Model T Ford
bearing down upon him but there are more
sinister charges against defenders of
the book as well copyright holders are
accused of being enemies of progress and
democracy library has grown under the
weight of our production many look
forward to the day in which we can eat
the rise books online and commit with
the director of the binary library Frank
Turner calls bibliographic euthanasia
but those who hate and fear the book
have populated its history from the
beginning the banning of books is still
a national headline as well as a recent
presidential campaign issue but even
more insidious is the prediction of the
books demise by enthusiasts of the
Internet one has to wonder why the
rhetoric against books has turned so
hostile is it because books still matter
my own personal library does not seek
revenge against the internet but am I
alone in detecting the aggressive tone
of those who celebrate the virtual
library at the expense of the physical
book does one technology necessarily
obliterate another did the television
destroy the radio it's difficult not to
sound threatened when defending the book
especially when the enemy is a book that
assumed that the war is already won
Steve Jobs of apple recently said that
he wasn't even interested or gonna
bother to enter the e-book reader market
because that's not what the world wants
no one reads books anymore he said it's
over and just several days ago a Los
Angeles Times article quoted Marcus
malesis zuniga founder of the political
website that daily kos who said about
those who fear the google book project
like natural selection there are species
that adapt to the changing environment
around them and thrive and others die
off the article also quotes stephen
dubner co author of the best-selling for
economics who said the crabbiness that
emanates from a certain breed of thinker
writer agreed that i generally admired
by the way about how the Internet's
cornucopia of information is destroying
book culture is based upon fear of
change than anything most people don't
even like to change the part in their
hair asking them to accept a change in
the way words are dispersed through
culture is a bit much Zuniga adds we no
longer have to depend on the so-called
or self-appointed experts to tell us
what we should think so it's come to
this the day when the self-appointed
experts who write blog write books
rather are finally taken down by the
self-appointed experts who write blogs
and whom should we trust the career
experts who write books and deliberate
over their content while researching for
years or the temporary experts who form
the chattering class on the blogosphere
now I don't hate blogs or internet
writing I love them I read them I
recognize that what goes on and them
though is different than what goes on in
books and I don't believe that the
expansion and growth of the Internet has
to mean the death of books so for a time
for a personal true confession
I love books more and I always have as a
son of immigrant parents I befuddled and
even alarmed my parents buy my affection
for books I took any chance to lose
myself in bugs though I've always regard
reading as more of an engagement than
escapism go outside my father used to
yell at me and during grade school I
would sometimes forgo lunch asking my
parents for the 25 cents to buy a hot
lunch while telling the school cafeteria
I was going home for lunch then I would
wait in the in the woods behind the
school during the lunch break hoarding
my change until I had enough to buy a
book well I collected enough to have a
little library I challenged my sister to
blindfold me and test my ability to name
a book and its publisher by touch and
smell alone it's a little obsessive I
know but I was right more times than not
and these books awakened me tension as a
reader I spent as much time trying to
suspend my awareness of a book as a
medium and getting lost in the dream of
its narrative and I've devoted my entire
adult life to publishing and despite
that I still think books matter or ought
to however there's a lot of evidence
that points to a troubled future for the
book here are some stats the progress an
international reading literacy study
reports that reading writing and
comprehension tests taken by ten year
old children around the world reveal
declining literacy levels both the US
and the UK lost six points in the last
five years ranking respectively number
18 and 19 globally to any a reports made
national headlines when they revealed
that literary reading in America is not
only declining rapidly among all groups
but the rate of decline has accelerated
especially among the young the second
report further complained that educators
and publishers contribute to a general
culture which does not encourage or
reinforce reading a much-publicized
report from ithaca university publishing
in a digital age reviews the seemingly
limitless range of opportunities for a
faculty member to distribute his or her
work from setting up a web page or blog
to posting an article to a working paper
website or institutional repository to
including it in a peer-reviewed journal
or book consequently nearly all
intellectual effort results in some
of publishing so what to do telling us
that reading books is good for us is not
persuasive no one enjoys how their
leisure behavior is being judged that's
a losing battle like the independent
bookseller who's in lecturing their
communities to buy local as if buying
Amazon were a moral issue it's not and
booksellers need more compelling reasons
to secure their customers loyalties as
do publishers if it proves true that we
prefer getting our news and our
entertainment from streaming media
television and hyperlink texts what does
that mean for us as human beings does
the book still matter in our evolution
as a species well it lose out to content
that is born digital it's not just
information but entire generations of
people that are set to be born digital
as well and what does it mean to call a
group that digital information first
that presumes a certain kind of
affluence the digital digital generation
has to be able to afford access to
computers and the web in all that
implies second it's simply not true that
this current college generation does not
read books they read books with that
assignment works for them the national
association of college stores reports
that only thirty percent of their stores
are equipped to deliver textbooks as
ebooks and within those stores only
fifteen percent of students prefer
ebooks to printed text books so if
America is a nation built on ideas
rather than manufacturing publishing is
that industry in which they meet
technology is where the expression of
desire meets the undertow of fear and
knowledge requires tools that can make
our lives smarter easier better and more
pleasurable that's all certainly for
good but our zeal for the new technology
needs to be tempered with the skeptical
awareness of its implications as a
culture were always better at gauging
what there is to gain rather than what
there is to lose Google of course is the
elephant in the room the big engine of
change having scanned the giant
libraries of Harvard Stanford Michigan
Oxford in your public library they have
made available millions of works that
were orphaned by the radical
and out of copyright status Google's
goal is to build a comprehensive library
of all the books in the world of virtual
Alexandria publishers while wary have
profited from the disinterment of their
deep backless into the light of day by
Google searches the long tail made
famous by Chris Andersen shows that
while only about two percent of the new
of the nearly 200,000 books published
each year sell over 5,000 copies the
rest are born directly into the long
tail or the remainder bin the publishing
industries equivalent of direct to DVD
so writing about the idea of universal
library excite some people to a state of
utopian hysteria Kevin Kelly is the
self-appointed Senor maverick of Wired
magazine and you've got to love that
title senior implies Authority maverick
implies iconoclast but together they
grant him the power to call anyone he
disagrees with a useless and obstructive
dinosaur and anyway didn't the last
election proved that we always don't go
for the senior maverick but at any rate
Kelly writes that plans like Google's
will allow all and this is we have to
sort of get expansive in cosmic all the
books in the world become the single
liquid fabric interconnect words and
ideas the universal library and its
books will be unlike any library or
books we have known pushing us rapidly
toward that Eden of everything and away
from the paradigm of the physical paper
tone is the hot technology of the search
engine what these great digital
libraries will accomplish hopefully is a
conversation among themselves sharing
patterns of use and user created created
metadata recording behaviors and
interests of readers books will
reference other books and drill down to
source materials in a sense these
digital libraries will breathe life into
the countless numbers of footnotes
computed over centuries but even then it
will never be complete by Google's own
estimate there have been over 100
million books published only about five
or ten percent of those are in print
twenty percent printed between the 15th
century in 1923 are out of copyright the
rest some 75 percent of all books ever
printed our orphans in copyright but out
of print books are only a part often a
selective synthesis of the record of
human experience
any claim to an exhaustive an
encyclopedic human record is merely a
pipe dream nonetheless the Google
library project is a great boon to
scholars in the bookless future david a
bell at scholar of european history and
politics writes the following fantasy as
he's doing research for a book on the
culture of war in Napoleonic Europe I'm
in a coffee shop on my university campus
a passage from Evan Burke's letters on a
regicide piece comes to mind but I can't
remember the exact wording finding the
passage as little as five years ago
would have required going to the library
locating the book on the shelf or not
and paging through the text in search of
the half-remembered material instead on
my laptop I open Internet Explorer
connect the wireless campus Network
seconds later i found the entire text
online i search for the words armed
doctrine and up comes the quote total
time elapsed less than a minute it's
pretty cool description right a new and
hyper convenient world scholarship in
the humanities and social sciences
revolutionized by the new information
technology which has put so many so much
primary and secondary source material
online but the great irony if not the
blind spot in the description is that
all of this hyperlinked research in the
world collapsed of time and travel is in
service of nothing other than the
writing of his next book so but to
Professor bells credit he quickly
darkens his fantasy into dystopian
shadows will the internet change not
only what scholars read but also how
they read those reading online tyrus
more quickly encouraged us to skim and
diminish our actual critical engagement
with a text these are important
questions and bear some reflection first
I'd like to try to get at the experience
or character of reading a book a line
from the tablet to the scroll to the
codex to the printed book we have been
looking for the optimal device for
recording information since reading
developed in the first place portability
and usability distinguished the book
from its inception which explains why it
has lasted some 700 years technology did
not destroy the concept of the book it
enhanced its nature and quickened its
production the rise of computers at
first did not threaten the book either
the screens of PC
we're friendlier to spreadsheets and
information that needed to be scrolled
through rather than read through users
of pcs prefer to toggle between
applications rather than proceed
sequentially through a linear document
sustained reading on a large screen
makes the eyes glaze over in the
backache most troubling concentration
fails attention wanders he wants to scan
and skim toggle and hyperlink reading
on-screen makes you want to do what it's
easy to do their search and discover
strategize how to get the information
you need you're not forced to surrender
to the organizing principles established
by the author or painstakingly follow
the path of argumentation she's laid for
you you won't necessarily have to make
marginal notes of themes to trace
throughout the text and circle footnotes
whose source you want to check online
it's all a click away but you're also
missing something important searching
around in an electronic text you can
skim cut and paste but you will read
things out of a deliberate context and
sequence it will get to the nut more
quickly but you will miss out learning
how the author arrived at his or her
conclusions Mary Ann Woolf in our book
priest in the squid the story and
science of the leading brain writes how
we are how we read emails blogs
hyperlinks pop-up ads news alerts etc
require a very different intelligence
than that needed by sustained and deep
reading experience we may become mere
decoders of information according to
miss Wolfe whether the book can be
enhanced by becoming a hypertext online
is a very important question to
publishers and editors we need to
anticipate the new skills required for
preparing text that will spawn real time
discussions online writers will
negotiate collaborative development of
content that is never static always
expanding readers will personalize their
books with annotations and hyperlinks to
personal journals the beginning and
ending of texts will be porous and
shifting they will lead the reader to
discussion forums social bookmarking
sites reader reviews and then further
open those venues to email lists and
social networks to my mind all these
benefits enhance the experience of deep
reading in a book to some extent it's
what should happen
after a group of people read a book
whether in a book group or a classroom
that spills over into a cafe or online
but it is not a replacement is there a
downside to this exciting prospect only
insofar as the futuristic fantasy
rejects the centrality of the book or
sees the book outside the universal
library as a fish out of an aquarium
gasping for air the institute for the
future of the book talks about the
emergence of the networked book the book
as a place as a social software a
sustained intellectual experience a
mover of ideas reinvented and appeared
to peer ecology a good future of the
book is one that combines the best
qualities of physical books with the
best qualities of the network at last a
reasonable nuanced vision of the future
of the book that protects intellectual
legacy and the physical craftsmanship
while ushering it into a new partnership
with new technology books still matter
in this universe and will not be
replaced by the blogosphere and as
Alberto Manuel writes it is interesting
to note how often a technological
development such as Gutenberg's promotes
rather than eliminates that which is
supposed to supersede one has to wonder
whether there will be a cognitive cost
to the migrating of scholarship away
from books I think of my own behavior
online versus browsing the stacks of a
library when I first came to Yale some
six years ago I spent the Saturday
wandering around the stacks in Sterling
and want nothing more than to be locked
in never leave the building again in
order takeout for the rest of my life
leave me here I'll be just fine but
browsing the stacks was a kind of
invitation to serendipity I was excited
by the distractions I fine on the way to
what I was looking for researching a
line I feel more as if I were playing a
video game dodging pop-up ads as if I
were finding asteroids with a joystick
the kinds of things that came my way or
impositions rather than accidents
imposed on me by mysterious and possibly
venal algorithms rather than discovered
by curiosity another discomforting
aspect of the surgeon parented that the
very agency that allows you to collect
information is collecting information
about you not the sound of the brother
alarm it is important to know that
debate our content providers and search
engines are for-profit corporations
whose motives
best not transparent to use the
collaborative filtering of some search
engines is to dance with a partner who
has long hands as my mother used to warn
my sister online marketing strategies
want to disguise themselves as a service
customized to your needs rather than a
tool to manipulate your desires in a
medium that is too new to learn defenses
against a public annotation of a digital
text is called a tag I often feel like
I'm playing tag when reading or
responding on the blog strategizing how
to out run or hide from or make contact
with whoever is it unlike that singular
attention the printed book relies on the
internet needs a multiplicity of users
who believe in it like an audience
clapping for Tinker Bell to survive even
as web indexing proves our online
writing to be less original than we
thought we shout louder to be recognized
within the den the question becomes not
so much who is able to be heard but just
whom ought to be listened to the
democratic ideal guarantees that every
voice can be heard but it does not
insist that every voice must be heard
who decides which voice should rise
above the noise of the blogosphere and
the noise of democracy traditionally
that has been the job of the publisher
to select developed edit to equip with
the leo graphic back matter to design
and manufacture in the age of
information in which research is not
only accessible but ubiquitous it's
imperative that we beg ask ourselves the
question what needs to be a book now
more than ever there's no secret that
university presses have experienced the
crisis in the last decade constriction
of library budgets continued
specialization of academic disciplines
have diminished readers of scholarly
monographs production costs have
increased use books cut into back the
sales course packs cannibalize adoption
market for textbooks an internal study
proved that we lose an average of ten
thousand titled ten thousand dollars per
title published we rely more and more on
outside subsidies from authors and
institutions so the marketplace itself
demands that we ask that question what
needs to be a book in particular what
needs to be a scholarly monograph aside
from tenure and career advancement
issues what does a University Press have
to publish and what is a monograph any
webster's has an inelegant definition a
written account of a single thing the
chair of our publications committee
david brown which once defined it as a
word of scholarship that will not sell
many copies until it does at which point
it becomes a gem of scholarship while
there was certainly a twinkle in his eye
the distinction has become actually
useful one and even prompted a spirited
conversation at a recent agenda lyst
publications committee meeting we
started with thinking about what
qualities the scholarly monograph and
the gem of scholarship might share
things like original primary research a
blindness to fashion a love of the
ignored in the arcane providing the
culture a way of keeping its neglected
history warm a rigorous methodology a
compound argument capable of advancing a
dozen or more layers a scholarly
apparatus that not only amplifies the
text but which enables the reader to
reconstruct and replicate the original
research to test the authors conclusions
or to use the same material to different
ends so where then might the two part
company how could a monograph be cut to
reveal its lapidary and gem like
qualities well in this in this case we
identified that the research might
demonstrate a passionate commitment and
almost athletic joy in uncovering and
managing masses of material a structure
that invents a new model of managing
that complexity a prose that contributes
terminology to lingua franca discipline
it challenges you can be understood by
the educated non-specialist as I n stein
said everything should be as simple as
possible but no simpler a book that
crosses disciplines with ease and learns
how to listen to its own internal echoes
and while perhaps narrow in scope that
book feels close you can feel the breath
of its intellect on the page you all
know what I'm talking about I'm sure
you've all been entranced by the
seamlessness of a narrative or dazzled
by the marshaling of dozens of arguments
in the service of grand theory you have
been transformed within the alchemy of
literature you have been moved by a book
so I hope I've made clear that the
defense of the book does not require the
trashing of digital culture books want
to enter
chip in which the best qualities in both
print and digital contents can be
amplified and mutually agreed eyes the
e-reader for instance knows that
technology does not need to destroy the
innovation whose shoulders it stands on
what the sony reader and the amazon
kindle try to do is to simulate the book
to replicate the experience of reading a
single book while traveling with the
portability of an entire bookshelf of
content so far sales of these have been
modest but encouraging preparing for a
long flight to China recently I myself
downloaded some 50 books ranging from
the complete works of Shakespeare to a
couple dozen manuscripts yell will
publish in the next year I thought I
would be the picture of minimalist
school with a very discreet black
shoulder bag I would have my blackberry
my ipod and my Kindle but as I was
leaving the house I panicked my shut six
books in there just in case but I may be
able to retrain myself here and get used
to reading an entire book on a device
like watching a film on a cell phone or
shuffling an opera recording in my ipod
or eating dinner on a paperless plate
every night but the prospect of a
hyperlink device that will allow a
reader to plug into a portal library
portable library of books may be the
best argument for why books still matter
and if book publishers and digital
content providers take each other's
council the marriage should work
publishers will Commission select edit
peer-review designed and publish both in
print and electronic forms new books the
better the books and the more creative
its dissemination the healthier the
university press a word on the business
model it's not a law of nature that the
book a product of human intelligence and
creativity belongs in the public
comments to argue that books should be
given away free is to deny a scholar or
writer the right to engage in an act of
gainful employment in order to be
morally consistent those who protests in
the public Commons that information
wants to be free should also advocate
that tuitions want to be waived and
professors want to teach without
salaries but that Hill is a hard one for
the info Tolkien's to swallow the
relative future in which the universal
library is up and running free of cost
free of books the question on half of
them is then what a bookless world in
which people learn to read
and research by virtue of snippets and
tags and annotations and wiki research
will be a world of people who not only
won't be able to read books but won't be
able to write them and the record of
human experience several thousand years
evolved will be irrevocably changed so I
think there are two dominant fantasies
in reading that been implicit throughout
the talk each of which is valid and
which cannot help but embody religious
prototypes and the first is to look at
the Internet as a great big religious
metaphor of the cosmic consciousness the
planet six billion minds connected
together into an identical library
Walter benjamine in the letter to adorno
said well before either of them could
even conceive of a computer much less an
e-reader wrote the great work of the
future will consist of fragments torn
from the body of other work it is a
reassembly a patchwork quilt of meanings
already accomplished the second is the
image of the individual reader before
the universal library personally I
collect more books than I need or can
possibly even read in a single lifetime
visitors to my home sometimes as can be
really read all of these and the answer
of course is no but that isn't the point
the collector always wants to own more
that he can experience all at once it
needs to be enough to overwhelm there
must always be more possibility than
satisfaction and the collection is one
of the only ways to have too much and
not enough at the same time to be
consoled by what cannot be known
completely this is another way in which
reading a book serves some kind of
religion while immersed in a book I
always feel that that book was meant to
be read one reader at a time written
precisely for his or her particular
attention and object waiting to be lit
by a singular imagination the
interaction between reader and writer is
as intimate as a penitent and prayer if
it is well done a book will allow you to
suspend your awareness of the medium it
wants to be fed to the fires of your
attention to a demise and D materialized
like the Gnostics ol the other fantasy
of reading is the melding of multiple
consciousnesses into one giant text
exploding into levels of apprehension
enabled by radical technologies either
apprehension is lit from within by the
single and deliberate mind who
to reach another mind and that's why
books still better thank